Valérie elle entend que vous travaillez
Cissé je me travestis depuis l'âge de 01
quoi enfin je pense un petit peu un
petit peu plus tard quand même
et au départ c'était quoi au départ je
commençais à piquer les jupes de
matou et vos parents réagissaient
comment à l'époque on veut s'en fiche en
fin de compte de ces basculer ils
habitent la Russie en fin de compte et
puissant ils sont cool là-bas en fin de
compte c'est est-ce que vous êtes
travestis si là-bas ah oui oui à chaque
fois que j'y vais sans problème
et on vous regarde comment ah ben là
c'est tout naturel on se lave en fin de
compte ici c'est tout un chichi si
d'ailleurs je passe pour une femme je
passe dans la rue
les gens me prennent pour une nénette on
confond travesti et puis homosexuel et
dans le fond il se goure les gens parce
que au lieu de dire
un travelo c'est un mais c'est faux
c'est n'a aucun rapport